[Music]
okay everybody i am so thrilled today
because ray seahorn aka chris latimer
and cooper's bar which you can watch on
amc site and youtube for free is back on
the show today ray how you doing today
i'm doing great how are you
good i'm so excited to talk to you again
you're like i've already said this one
of my favorite actresses in the world so
this is really exciting and it's
exciting because oh yeah and and i love
that you're doing more stuff behind the
scenes too and what's really cool is
that you're one of the creators of this
project in cooper's bar so
what i did want to ask you is where did
this idea kind of begin or come from
well uh
this is an actual tiki bar in luma
stillow the character who plays the
league cooper um it is actually in his
yard and he and i yeah this was all real
we filmed it in his backyard um
and uh
lou um is a tremendous actor with an
incredible resume but he and i actually
met um at a boot camp this this workout
placed in glendale
um
and
uh same with the writers uh david
connolly and hannah davis law um and
then later nick morton
came on after we did a 10 minute short
and we created this series but that it
all originated just because
we had a bunch of uh friends and lou has
these insane stories that would happen
in his backyard where um
network executives are you know
co-mingling with uh
the barista he met that morning down the
street um and but you know then we had
to get to the work of like let's
actually do scripts because
we've all we've all been there we're at
two o'clock in the morning you think you
and your friends are so funny you should
have your own show and it's not true so
we had to we had to actually make sure
there was a script there
oh yeah i love that and it's interesting
too because you could tell watching this
show that there's got to be inspiration
from just stories and experiences you
guys had so i'm wondering with your
character of chris who's a tv executive
who they call the biggest dick in
hollywood was this character like
inspired like do you feel like you've
come across in your life in your career
people like chris
i have to say i am very fortunate that
um i have not but i am not i have not
produced or written before where i would
be subject to these rooms with these
kind of notes and stuff um
but i i do think i can say that uh david
hannah and nick had a good time um
exercising all of the note sessions that
they've had to sit through in their
lives and all their meetings and their
agents and all of that and i understood
that i was a i was a conduit for getting
these demons out for them
okay i love that that's a good answer
too and it's i like that answered smart
um i think you never know who's
listening right and i think people
sometimes forget to
how you have such a large amount of
actually comedy experience and that
you've done whitney and veep and they're
also doing the harper house now which is
also great so was there anything from
those projects though that you kind of
maybe brought to this comedy series like
things you've kind of learned about the
genre
uh yeah i mean i did uh
i did in theater when i was doing
theater in new york in washington dc uh
for about 12 years like i did comedy and
drama back and forth um
and it and then when i came out to la i
was cast in a sitcom called i'm with her
uh and
on abc and then from there just um
kept being called in and cast in sitcoms
and uh
as any actor will tell you you can only
be so lucky to be pigeonholed because
that means anybody's calling you at all
um
but it was surprising to me that uh
that people sort of didn't call you in
for drama then um but some did and that
includes the incredible um
casting directors um sharon bialy sherry
thomas and russell scott um who cast
breaking bad and they also cast uh uh
better call saul so they were calling me
in for dramas for years and years and
years um
for work that nobody ever saw never saw
the light of the day because i didn't i
didn't get them but um you know it ended
up being a body of work that they
could speak to vince and peter about um
when it came time to consider me for the
kim wexler role um but yeah it was uh it
was it was it was fun
uh
going back to doing um this very kind of
heightened broad comedy it was we had a
good time
yeah and you could tell you guys are
having a good time and there's a really
good chemistry between the cast here too
so it's cool to kind of see you play
around with these people and
do you ever sense when you're working
with maybe people that are lesser known
creatives do you feel like people are
intimidated by your star power now like
do you ever sense people nervous around
you is this something that kind of
happens now
um
[Laughter]
on our show these people uh have most of
the people on this have been friends of
mine for a while
so we didn't we didn't have much of that
issue i i don't know um
maybe later on in this series when more
people start coming in uh uh i don't but
i i don't know i've had i've had a few
occasions where i'm just talking to
someone in the business and then they
revealed to me that they were nervous
which i'm always surprised because
um yeah it's fun
now do you believe
comedic acting some people say is
actually
harder than dramatic acting are you
someone in that camp do you see them
kind of equal like how would you compare
the two
it really depends on the the script as
to as far as like what is technically
more uh
difficult um
but one does i do fall in the camp of
people that feels the need to
defend how difficult comedy is though
because
bizarrely
people still
think that it's easy um and tend to not
actually think of somebody who's doing
comedy really well as as
as a real and that's in quotations actor
or um
they are
they are equally difficult and the the
math and the science and the
the phonics uh and the timing that go
into doing comedy well is to be able to
do it
in a way that doesn't look like work um
and so you know you're you're striving
to actually prove to prove the
counterpoint is to make it look like
you're not doing anything all right
so that's that's always hard but they're
um
they're equally difficult and then even
within the genres there's um there's
like uh in um
in in better called saul sure it's easy
to look at really explosive scenes and
on other shows as well uh
as being like the hardest thing to do
but actually can be
very challenging
to do
the smaller scenes that are about the
fabric of a relationship to uh
do the teeth brushing scenes to do the
tv watching scenes um
because you need to
really trust uh in the
character you've built and the
relationship you've built and not overdo
anything and that connective tissue is
what makes the more explosive scenes on
the book ends of that work
wow that that's an incredible answer and
that that's good to hear too from
someone who has such experience in both
genres i really like that and
it's interesting too but that you're all
now picking up doing more stuff behind
the scenes and it's cool that your
executive producer here on this project
but that you also direct two episodes
and people were excited that you were
directing saul for the first time this
season
for you in general now is it is it
difficult like to get into characters
you're also acting in this and then turn
off the directing producing part in your
head or is it easy to kind of separate
that when you're on set
um it's
it is technically difficult and um when
i
when people saw 604 of saul that i
directed they're like wow you really
wanted to direct yourself in some major
scenes because it's very it's a very kim
wexler heavy episode with some extremely
challenging kim wexler scenes um but it
that was a calendar days slot kind of
thing that i was given that uh script it
was not purposefully picked that this
should be the one that i direct um
it is
it is there's no getting around that it
is logistically
challenging um
because
there's also the uh the prep time the
when you're when you're in prep which um
for any of your listeners that don't
know it is as long of hours and as
difficult as when you're actually
shooting it and that's the director's
prep of breaking down the episode and
scouting and going
going on scouts looking at locations and
deciding like does this room work would
the camera fit here do we need a crane
um
casting all the dayplayer parts uh
looking at costumes looking at props and
i was also shooting an episode while we
were doing that so
you need to be in two places at once um
and
uh
and then there's the actual shooting
where you're like running over to the
monitor and running back um thankfully
uh in both cases on cooper's uh where we
had to shoot very fast and furious in a
very short amount of time with not a lot
of money um
uh versus
saul um longer prep you know um
larger infrastructure but still in both
cases
people really really went out of their
way to give me um
to give me what i needed as a support
system to be able to do that everything
from we had a producing director michael
morris on better call saw this year and
he's directed a number of episodes and
he's been in the saul family for a while
but
he could be my eyes over in um video
village because when i'm in a scene
i owe it to
myself and i owe it to my scene partner
to be just playing kim wexler not
watching them with an observant
director's eye and it was important to
me to
to not
be observational when i'm when i'm in
those scenes of those people so
i would kind of set up a system where i
would ask and then on um on uh uh
cooper's bar um the wonderful director
anna remy borden um
we begged to come a d for us uh because
she's got such a brilliant producing and
directing mind that she was able to um
and she's a sought after
a.d but uh she same same thing she was
able to be my eyes and my ears when i
couldn't watch myself because you don't
have time to keep watching playback you
just there isn't enough hours in the day
that sun is gonna come up and these are
all night shoots right right no that
that's really interesting too and that's
a lot of really good info i could just
want to just take is tidbits there for
just film lessons that's really good
stuff and i'm i'm wondering too
from your angle as doing this directing
a lot more now do you have any
directors that kind of speak to you or
you look up to or that even you just
study in general when you kind of want
to kind of maybe
be inspired
um all of the better crosstall and
breaking bad directors
i mean truly it's a master class i just
like
i listen and i watch and i absorb um
pretty much every department there uh
actually no every department not pretty
much but
there
to learn more about what other people
are doing and contributing to this
collaborative art form makes you better
at your job as well so i i've always
wanted to learn even when it wasn't
about um directing i i like
understanding all the cogs in the wheel
um
and
i shadowed
quite a few of them um roberto barba
scott wyant um
uh michael slovis um for multiple
multiple episodes on hiatus for the
shows they were on um
uh and
uh michelle mclaren um
was a big uh help to me um
and
all of these people uh
they go about their process slightly
slightly differently uh and so everybody
has their own um particular language or
the way they draw out a shot lesson
certainly
vince gilligan and peter gould um have
allowed me to see their process
in such a detailed way that i feel
i mean what what a gift to be able to
listen to and talk to those guys for
seven years of my life um
so
i draw inspiration from them yes there's
people if i sat here and thought like
certainly i'm directors of
uh
films and other television shows but but
these people i have to say like i think
they're the i think they're the best of
the best and i've gotten to watch them
up close for seven years
yeah and that's great and it shows in
your work so far even just on saul like
how you're learning from the best and
you're you're producing you're
performing it and doing it great
everywhere so
i thank you
no problem and the thing too is you know
we're nearing the end of better call
saul now so do you feel emotionally
ready to say goodbye to the character
kim or is that something like as an
actor you can't prepare for like is she
part of your soul forever
ah i think she's probably part of my
soul forever i'll be i i was uh
very sad
when the show ended when it's your last
day of shooting and you drive away from
set um it was very emotional uh but
because it's still airing i feel like
the full weight of the show ending is
has not hit many of us um
because we're still promoting it and
we're still um
you know we're still taking this baby
around that we made to show people um
and
it'll probably hit me even more when
it's done done i'm
incredibly grateful though that to to
do the most
challenging work of my career
in the best role of my career the fact
that we had um critics and fans
uh receiving it so well um because you
could be doing the best work of your
life and no one saw it um
so
it does it does exist and it's out there
in the world and we we did the work and
um
it was challenging work uh beautifully
challenging and
it doesn't get any easier from here on
out the rest of the episodes are bananas
um
and uh
i'm grateful i i'm i'm grateful to have
done that work with those with that
particular group of people um
and i'm excited for it to be out there i
you know i'll be i'll be sad um she'll
probably always be a part of me
i love that answer and if i don't get to
talk to you again before the end of saul
i just want to thank you two for your
incredible performance as kim wexler
being super kind to people like me and
also the fan base and
kim to me is just a legend of character
that people won't forget and a legendary
performance people won't forget
and saying that if they don't nominate
you for the emmy in july i'm literally
going to quit the business as protest so
i i have a good feeling though and
either way there's an enemy for you in
my eyes and i think everybody knows
you're incredible in this and i'm gonna
miss it but overall thank you for being
so kind and everyone check out cooper's
bar for free now on amc.com and youtube
watch ray just kill it here it's linked
below
and of course buttercloth returns july
11. thank you so much ray for joining
thank you for such kind words that's so
funny
thank you no and i'm not just saying
that like it you really deserve that and
uh yeah and i can't wait to see what you
do next